[Musica]
[Applauso]
ognuno di noi
possiede una diversa prospettiva
dalla quale guarda al mondo e attraverso
la quale adesso si relaziona
io ad esempio il mondo
l'ho sempre guardato da così
non sto parlando di astratte
speculazioni sul fatto che per me la
musica sia tutto che la mia vita senza
sarebbe peggiore
sto parlando di un atto fisico empirico
ho passato in quella posizione
un tempo lunghissimo
i miei occhi hanno focalizzato quella
scena le mie braccia quei movimenti e le
mie orecchie soprattutto questi suoni
la risultante delle percezioni
sensoriali si è però costantemente
arricchita degli impulsi dati dalla
scena emotiva caratteriale e legati alle
esperienze della mia vita
dalla bambina
dirigente ma esuberante alla ragazza
brillante estroversa ancor più
esuberante che sono stata alla giovane
adulta che sono ora attenta e un po più
consapevole
in questa posizione
io ho sperimentato disciplina e
attenzione
divertimento ed entusiasmo
senso della libertà perfino erotismo e
poi ancora l'essere assertivi osare
oltre ogni sana soglia dell'auto
consapevolezza
e talvolta più recentemente anche la
preghiera
tanti colori e tanti umori mi hanno
attraversato la mente in quella
posizione
ci ho pensato ma onestamente non ne
conosco altre nelle quali sia trascorsa
così tanta vita
all'età di tre anni e mezzo mi sono
ritrovata questo pezzo di legno chiamato
violino tra le mani
e da allora non l'ho mai lasciato
una volta concluso il percorso
accademico ho incontrato il jazz e il
mondo dell'improvvisazione
che mi hanno stregata tal punto da
essere diventati il perno su cui ruota
il mio fare musica oggi
l'improvvisazione e la sperimentazione
sono gli elementi che ricerco in qualità
di musicista
tanto quanto rifuggo in qualità di
persona
amo il jazz le musiche improvvisate
perché sono tutto il contrario di me e
quindi forse in qualche modo si
completano
ognuno di noi possiede un diverso punto
di vista da cui guardare il mondo ma
ognuno di noi è anche una storia una
storia che si racconta
insieme a quella prospettiva giorno dopo
giorno
e che a volerla guardar bene
essa in realtà è costituita da centinaia
migliaia di altre storie che in essa si
intersecano
modificandola arricchendola
complicandola agitandola
alcune si avvicinano in punta di piedi
bussano alla nostra porta ci chiedono il
permesso di entrare
si ricavano uno spazio modesto e
discreto e una volta giunte alla loro
conclusione
nella stessa modalità
se ne vanno
altre invece non bussano alla nostra
porta
la sfondano
irrompono in maniera inaspettata e
imprevista
nella nostra vita
è prepotentemente ci chiedono di
affrontarle
a volte ci chiedono pure di diventarne i
protagonisti
ci sono storie che nascono
si sviluppano e arrivano al loro termine
nell'arco di una giornata
altri impiegano mesi anni
altri ancora si risolvono nel tempo di
uno sguardo
alcune storie prevedono la
partecipazione di moltissimi personaggi
altre
hanno un solo protagonista
personalmente amo le storie amo
raccontarle e sono una chiacchierona e
amo raccontarle attraverso il linguaggio
della musica attraverso questo strumento
la storia che vi racconto ora è quella
che ha ispirato il brano intitolato
minotaurus che suona ero tra poco
nato da un amore sbagliato contro il
volere degli dei e anche contro il
volere degli uomini
il minotauro essere brutale e deforme
viene rinchiuso in un labirinto di
specchi
dapprima confuso nel vedere come quelle
immagini la sua figura riflessa negli
specchi si comportino imitando ogni suo
movimento
col passare del tempo però il minotauro
acquistati fierezza
convincendosi di far parte di una
comunità di suoi simili con i quali e di
danza e dei quali arriva a credere egli
stesso ne è il dio
ma un giorno
scorge fra le figure di minotauri
danzanti un'immagine diversa
quella di una fanciulla dai capelli
rossi che non gli obbedisce
e insieme a quella ne scorge mille altre
identiche
il minotauro viene preso dalla gioia
incontenibile per non essere finalmente
più solo e la cerca
mentre è la scappa dal minotauro e dalle
immagini di esso
fino a cadergli tra le braccia
unendosi a lui in una danza di gioia e
di paura
liberazione e di morte
[Musica]
chi best business
cita
[Musica]
i test gioia bevin fan per
david filo e jerry green funky
dance
[Musica]
a
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
corona
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
yara
credo
che ogni volta che iniziò a suonare
possa incominciare una storia
e mi piace pensare che essa non debba
necessariamente finire
una volta che avevo smesso di suonare
[Applauso]